Quais são os perigos do alisamento do
cabelo com formol? As famosas
progressivas. Imagina, você chega no
salão, quer domar um freez, a cabeleira
abre o potinho da progressiva e de
repente aquele cheiro forte começa a
arder os olhos. Muita gente pensa: "Ah,
é normal, beleza, exige sacrifício." Mas
e se eu te dissesse que esse cheiro pode
esconder riscos sérios pra sua saúde,
que nem sempre o rótulo conta toda a
história? Vamos direto ao ponto. No
Brasil, uso de formal como alisante já é
proibido. O que a legislação permite é
formal só como conservante até 0,2% e em
endurecedor de unhas até 5%. Acima disso
e principalmente quando é usado para
alisar o cabelo, vira problema de saúde
pública e sim de polícia sanitária. Se o
produto promete liso duradouro com
calor, desconfie. É a combinação
perfeita para liberar gás de forma
deído, aquele que irrita os olhos, pele,
vias aéreas. E o pior, muita coisa sem
formol por aí já foi flagrada contendo
substâncias que viram formaldeído quando
aquecidas. É tipo jeitinho químico no
rótulo. Mas qual é o perigo real? Vamos
por partes. O fomaldeído é classificado
como carcinogênico em humanos, grupo um.
Então, a exposição repetida está ligado
sobretudo a câncer, nasofaríngo, aumento
de risco de leucemias. Além disso, mesmo
em curto prazo, pode dar dor de cabeça,
tontura, náusea, tosse, chiado,
irritação de pele e olhos. E não é
exagero, é ciência. E é por isso que
vários países apertaram a fiscalização.
Sabe aquele momento do secador e da
prancha, quando sobe uma fumacinha, ali,
a coisa aperta. Medições e salões
mostraram que durante o blow dry a
chapinha, a concentração de forma
aldeída no ar pode ultrapassar os
unimitacional,
ou seja, além de te expor, expõe quem
trabalha no salão o dia inteiro. E teve
caso clássico de produto sem
formaldeído, que analisado em
laboratório tinha formaldeído de rodo,
sacou? O tamanho do risco, tá? Então é
só pegar progressiva sem formol, ok?
Calma. Os substitutos mais comuns, o
ácido glioxílico também acenderam
alertas recentes. Estudos e séries de
casos internacionais mostraram quadros
de lesão renal aguda por depósito de
oxalatos indes após procedimentos com
produtos sem formol à base de
glioxílico. Pessoas jovens aparentemente
saudáveis voltando o salão com vômitos,
dor abdominal, queda do volume urinário
e creatinina marcador do sangue lá em
cima. Em alguns relatos, a intervenção
rápida com vitaminas do complexo B, como
tiamina e piridoxina ajudou, mas isso
não torna o procedimento seguro. O
recado é claro, sem formol não significa
sem risco. E não é só questão de rótulo.
Na prática, o calor da prancha libera
mais vapores. O salão às vezes não tem
exaustão, não tem circulação de ar. E a
cliente vai respirando aquilo por uma
hora, duas horas, sem falar na
profissional que repete esse ritual
todos os dias. Isso explica porque
agências de saúde do trabalho reforçam
há mais de uma década que muitos
alisantes liberam formaldeído acima do
permitido e exigem controles rigorosos
como ventilação, equipamento de proteção
individual, monitoramento do ar,
informação transparente. Se isso já é
puxado para quem trabalha, imagina para
quem não tem nenhum controle em casa ou
salão improvisado, que é muito comum no
Brasil. Beleza? Então, o que que eu faço
se eu quero o cabelo mais alinhado, sem
me arriscar? Aqui vai um plano pé no
chão na linha da visão integrativa e
prática do dia a dia. Primeiro,
questione o rótulo e o fornecedor. Peça
a ficha de informação de segurança.
Procure por nomes como formaldeído,
metilenoglicol, formalina ou compostos
liberadores de formaldeído. Se tiver
ácido glioxílico,
fuja. Segundo, se ainda assim for fazer
algum procedimento químico, exija salão
com ventilação real, seja exaustão,
janela aberta, não basta. Tempo de
exposição reduzido, é importante
proteção ocular e respiratória para
profissional e para você se aplicável.
Terceiro, considere alternativas menos
agressivas, como tratamentos
temporários, sem aquecimento intenso,
escova modeladora, livins,
termoprotetores, técnicas de finalização
que alinham fio sem selar com química
pesada. Por fim, prioridade total a
gestantes, as máticos, pessoas com
rinite e pele sensível. Evite a todo
custo e por favor, nada de progressiva
caseira com formol do tio do bairro, ok?
Do lado de dentro, na abordagem
funcional do cabelo, do couro cabeludo,
lembre de ajustar o que sustenta o fio.
Proteína suficiente na dieta, ferro e
zinco em dia, checar vitamina D, ô3, se
houver queda e quebra, manejar estresse
e sono, não adianta plastificar por fora
se o fio está nascendo fraco por dentro.
Pequenas trocas de rotina, lavagem mais
suave, reduzir chapinha diária, protetor
térmico de verdade, somam muito ao longo
de mês. Então, pense como investimento,
menos química hoje, mais saúde capilar
amanhã. E se eu já fiz progressiva e me
senti mal? Interrompa a exposição.
Procure atendimento se houver falta de
ar ou chiado ou dor no peito ou vômitos
ou urina reduzida nas horas seguintes ao
procedimento. Leve o nome do produto
utilizado. Se o profissional do salão
também sentiu irritação ocular ou
respiratória, vale acionar a vigilância
sanitária local. Isso protege todo
mundo. Nos Estados Unidos, o FTA tem
apertado o cerco e já notificou marcas
famosas. No Brasil, Anvisa reforçou o
alerta em 2025. A tendência global é
restringir cada vez mais esses
procedimentos que liberam o formalde
deído. Em resumo, progressiva com
formolada química e a sem formol quando
usam o ácido glioxílico, não são passe
livre. podem trazer riscos sérios,
inclusive pros seus rins. Seu cabelo
merece cuidado, mas não improviso
perigoso. Quer liso? Que seja com
informação na mão, salão responsável e
estratégias que respeit saúde, porque no
fim não tem beleza que compense colocar
sua respiração, sua pele e seus insinha
de fogo. Combinado? Compartilha esse
conteúdo com aquela amiga que ama um
liso escorrido e vamos espalhar a saúde
e não fumaça.